let's take a closer look at the fighting
on the ground and i'm joined now by
former british army intelligence officer
and chief executive of mckenzie
intelligence forbes mackenzie forbes
hello again um stuart they're reporting
from the east of the country what's
happening in the east in terms of the
fighting but the russians have
concentrated their efforts around
severed done-esque um and in supporting
those efforts they need to look after
the supply lines and there's lots of
artillery being used which we will come
on to and but the supply lines go from
the russian border down to isiam and
there's a main road that goes from is
from israel to donetsk and they're
really digging in and protecting that
with fortifications and mines
and there's a changing nature of the war
that we're now starting to pick up and
starting to see and before we talk about
that they kind of tit-for-tat the
exchanging of uh geographies to the
south of several donetsk has continued
over the last 24 to 48 hours let's talk
about that changing face of the war
they are into a new phase aren't they
especially around that area what what's
happening there it absolutely feels that
way the maneuverist aspect of the war
from the early days has now ceased uh
mario paul in the south has now come to
a conclusion and in severe donetsk um
the the russians are now taking the city
uh block by block and they're doing that
and with artillery pieces such as this
the bm 21 grad grad russian for hail old
piece of equipment from the 1960s and
but effective in reducing and raising an
urban landscape and then occupying that
landscape and what we're seeing is in
the next slide
is that we'll see a picture of the bm21s
in action at nine to eleven kilometers
the northeast of donetsk if you look at
the uh the vehicle is about to be ringed
now you can see there's actually a blast
mark a darker area to the um bottom
right hand side as i look at it and
that's where rockets have been fired and
the second um
grad has not been fired yet and they'd
be assessed to be um more bm-21s those
rocket launchers in the um forest you
can see that via the tracks
now you mentioned mario paul and um has
the russians occupy them and their
reports that they simply can't provide
basic public services in those cities
that's right now the areas to the south
which are occupied um there's a
russian-esque um system of political uh
bureau administration be put into place
that is not keeping pace with the
requirements for the medical uh
facilities and kirsten we're hearing
about and there may be a likely impact
from cholera in
my apple
okay forbes mackenzie thanks a lot very
much
well if you scan the qr code on your
screen right now you can listen to the
latest sky news daily podcast our chief
correspondent stuart ramsey and his
producer dominique van hierden recently
returned to the ukraine for the first
time since they were ambushed and
stewart was shot in early march
following that russian invasion they
speak to today's host dominic wagon
about how much the country has changed
since then as well at what as well as
what it was like for them personally as
they've revisited people who've helped
them you can also subscribe to the daily
wherever you get your podcasts